والى المغرب الان ومراكش تستضيف اعمال
الدوره الاولى من المناظره الافريقيه للحد
من المخاطر الصحيه
واسعه هذه
المناظره الاولى من نوعها تنظم اذن من طرف
وزاره الصحه المغربيه بشراكه مع جمعيه طب
الادمان المغربيه على مدار ثلاثه ايام
ابتداءا اذا من اليوم يشارك في اعمالها
خبراء وذكر ووزراء من 60 دوله من بينهم
النرويج وكندا والولايات المتحده
والامارات المناظره الافريقيه الاولى اذا
تنظم ما حسب القائمين عليها في فتره يعرف
فيها العالم تدخلات وتدخل الازمات الامنيه
والاقتصاديه والبيئيه وما يترتب عنها من
انعكاساتين اجتماعيه وانسانيه واسعه خاصه
في الفضاء المغربي وفي دول جنوب الصحراء
الافريقيه كما يبحث عن المشاركون سبل
توحيد الجهود الافريقيه في مواجهه مختلف
التهديدات ورسم استراتيجيات استقبائيه